make change the book is out
um while we're talking politics i was
very very uh
annoyed for you over this past few days
yeah that's okay it's funny because like
you said like
i feel like once every five or six weeks
you trend on twitter
yeah and for me it was frustrating
because people were putting a tweet that
you had
up i don't know during the uh primaries
it was even before the primaries it was
i wrote a tweet in 2018 before the
democratic primaries even started
before bernie had even announced and i
hadn't actually endorsed bernie yet
and sincerely i was open to endorsing
someone other than bernie and i
i said that to bernie and others that i
wanted to see who all was going to wow
and uh i just said i know two candidates
that i won't be
endorsing for for the democratic
nomination
joe biden and kamala harris because of
their role in mass incar
in helping build mass incarceration uh
it wasn't that i would
never support them in life or never
support their policies but i didn't
endorse them yeah they were and not even
i wasn't even talking about for
president it was
the tweet was actually in a tweet thread
people wrote i was going to say
the one tweet that they tried to use
against you from this week
was was like the last tweet of like four
or five
yeah i wrote i wrote so that's what they
do so i wrote a tweet thread
that was also still very critical of
and just like i have a friend jamal true
love
and uh jamal was wrongly convicted of
murder
in san francisco a murder he didn't
commit spent eight years in prison he
was convicted by kamala harris it ruined
his life
wow and the city of san francisco had to
pay 10 million dollars
in that wrongful conviction suit and it
changed
jamal in immeasurable ways so like
as district attorney she was deeply
problematic
all i wanted people to say and then
people start saying stupid stuff like is
sean paid by the dnc
i was never paid by bernie i never
worked for bernie i was always a
volunteer
i've never been paid by a politician a
day of my life
and i've studied kamala's record
i have no desire to be buddies or
friends with her or any or
or with her campaign she's gotten
significantly better and she's improved
on
issues like she now stands against
qualified immunity for police
she's one of the few senators who who
does so uh
she now stands for the full
decriminalization and legalization of
marijuana which joe biden doesn't
and she she was a co-sponsor of a bill
with cory booker
which was probably the best bill ever on
expunging people's records who were ever
convicted in the war on drugs
and she was a co-sponsor of that bill
and so listen i know that
she and joe biden they're not my dream
come true
they weren't in my neither were in my
top ten
and yet joe yeah especially joel
and because here's the thing uh i can't
say
for joe what i can say for kamala she
has
she has evolved and improved and if
people don't want to give her credit for
that
that's more says something about them
but
joe hasn't and joe joe basically still
won't acknowledge his role in building
mass incarceration
he still won't stand for the most basic
policies that are actually popular among
democrats including universal health
care
including basic criminal justice reform
policies
and so and it's not because of his age i
don't i don't accept that
it's him i saw bernie he lacks a lot of
humility joe biden doesn't have a lot of
humility
oh he doesn't man and he he couches it
in some
other things but no no he's uh
you know he's always been that way and
um
you know i i also gave probably for the
first time in
two years i gave joe biden a compliment
in that tweet thread
to say that i was surprised that he
picked kamala because she was the only
person that ran against him
that walloped him several times she went
in
on him during the the uh i watched every
debate and
yeah she she really held him over the
fire we couldn't
bernie it's not in his it's not his
style
to hit people like that right and
all of us who were in his corner wanted
him to throw
knockout punches against everybody and
it's just he's just
a good good guy and kamala was a former
prosecutor what we were just talking
about
and she hammered joe biden on the crime
bill she hammered him on his role
of between integration and segregation
and they were they were probably two of
the low moments for joe biden in the
whole debate
and um so i i said i thought it took
some level of guts for him to pick the
candidate
who hammered him the hardest